welcome back our studio to st.
who
dominated almost all chess
tournaments who is possible what is happening with
Magnus what is happening to him and not
asking a question it was clear that he
would be the first I don’t know the exact
answer to him in principle, it’s disgusting in general about the
fact that of course the level of the game, well, let’s say,
it remains to wait  the
number of sevks for tournaments of this
level is much better.
In general, it seems to me related to general
fatigue, because of course the tiger is
impossible to play so much, but I found the case
with signed ones and because
all kinds of paper grow smaller than the rest, this is also
equal to the classic tournament this year, but
it seems to me just  such a
psychological effect works, after all,
only victory is expected from him, and the escape is brilliant  it’s harder
every time the payout here he wins even
more if it’s such a fine
tuning something breaks and then
it’s hard for us to get you like a scantre and a hand
there that has little time flowers for it
classical chess rapid I think that
there we’ll say porthos vanya to us
it just turned out to be just
critical, besides, I can’t explain
how the general could have suffered on h7 h4 the position was
technically won, I could have
fought there in a minute to bring it up and then
just automatically
won such positions just
literally next to the flag here 15 in
time
roughest yawns and medicines after that,
everything was revealed to him help even this
park to play is not obliged not to
run away not to play until 5 most likely
I’d better find scientists for this without amateurs
before light figures do not
interact and further vikasol can’t
just find himself because it’s clear that
he does a lot of strange things,
let's say 2-port with how many
blacks he gave away, it means he was
offended by one  blitz
in general, the choice will be finished off and it’s amazing to play with
quarantine or some kind of closed
Indian waste they don’t even repair boxing
arranges the pieces exactly or
plays French pin about karate is also
in bad shape
psychological just such a law one
psychological he and he even the choice of the
opening surprises me there even the
participant that he is in the games that you play as an
offer the sound plays
and the edge is also such so such a palette
and action in general that something broke,
apparently they were repaired, but  you
personally have had such moments in your career where you
had to cope with
such a psychological situation at home
and wide and didn’t play so much
never always had time the year there were
unsuccessful tournaments then time to
get ready to return in principle during the
tournament,
well, perhaps the most  i
had a bad tournament rapido this is russia with national teams the
teacher us -2 simply dial this
in  it looks like it was there in 2002
, one still not already under forty,
in general, now a little bit still not 330, and
yet, in general, it seems to me that,
in general, the pressure is huge,
because such a brilliant year is really
a brilliant step there  you all want
every feat to accomplish something,
and then it starts again in rapid speed closer
there, in general, because the whole moment
happens, I didn’t have time to gather all the
next couple there in 15 minutes and, in general,
it can roll very much until we see
when there is a question of God, I even speak
English  commentary in English, as
it were, a section like bios, I say that
it annoys me more when you can,
and there it’s all there and just keep your head down
when once just a gang in front of
lovers just laughs for 1 month
substitutes everything in a row, but the computer
submits an exchange of 4 plus 5  I took my father
when I sculpted them in 2 moves lost the
edge I won about the port,
but I went to inspect the tires there for three
minutes, then go to the oil and  then
further with flour to the streets 5 and further I
don’t think it’s packed 4 just well, in general, I don’t,
yes, I think that all the same, of course,
related 1 systems are replayed and the fact
that this year turned out to be just crazy
due to the fact that the last sulu 4 tournaments of
which  there should not have been a
bush calendar and in general our entire schedule was
opposite, it was specially made
more tournament this year, it was considered
that it would be an empty candidate truly
hurt the olympiad the boy has no before
that you can fill him with the more
interest in africa and where to add the tournament and
suddenly January  I found out that when
4 qualifying tournaments are going
to be included which I was on the calendar and it
just created, he taught for incredible
tension, of course, to be honest, I
sympathize with everyone there, and that’s
probably what I wanted to ask about this that
some kind of congestion is really
felt by the players what to do with it
there is, let’s say, maxim refuses,
it seems to me that something is from the grand sv
garden
when they need os  fabi
plays a lot, I didn’t have such a
problem, it’s clear that everyone has their own
norm, it’s clear that there’s only no
general advice here, I won’t beat individual ones,
but it’s clear that in order to play it’s impossible
in general, I would like it to be formed there as a
hit calendar, not the last one
, because  next year
we are reducing the forest of tournaments, it’s understandable
there we are already planning to reduce the number
because there will be a candidate no one knows
where the truth will be reassembled, it’s also
unknown somewhere the guys are known, that
is, it’s clear that when we see how
to load
with gifts I try to reduce the number of the
tournament as a whole, in general  Of course,
I would like to see how there was more
consistency in the Mistral calendar,
because we still have tournaments,
as if from the past, I understand all these
Bundesligas there, French, isn’t it all
important and of course the match, but these are all tournaments
that seem to come from 80 90  years,
now we even see that the players are just, well,
really loaded into the already grand prix  and there
every one through the tap 6 now and there’s no way to
catch what is probably when it is necessary to
coordinate the calendar in general and because
I’m Lisa what is the norm of the umbrella or
what is the norm of Magnus or what is the norm of
rouge I set how they play now
and it’s clear what they are and not overheat you
already in paris did something insane
murder because it's not on the flag
later the last park royal crown there on the
flags there they did God knows
what's there winning there a hundred times
won there like one I understand
flaunts 8 seconds and you once  I was
blown away by the Communist Party, it was in Paris for three
minutes, they take away all the perseverance
to attack, however, in the summer and collect after
something more, something happened and it
seems to me that a lasting call is serious,
but it seems to me that Carrick, how to have,
may not allocate enough time for
physical training, here with  such a
load
when the case is here the flight is still a tuner, it’s the
same you pass and no further there or on the
train there is, after all, there I was in Abidjan and
there the ninja shines and in general  it will be pouting
all the same, that is, it’s clear that of course yes
yes yes yes somehow maintain its shape
and then, as it were, everyone, as it can already,
but
in general, on this stack object, the
advantage is in general, but so far it has
unnoticed, it seems to me that here to
look at kotova  Bejan Cossack tournaments were
held, and paris and sanguis for the mushroom,
so far, in general, it’s just clear that,
let’s say the tournament there, the number of rough
sivks will increase because the tank in winter
is already growing here, as it is, there are
some things there, a person yawned there, he
got carried away with something, but here it’s just  key pad
primitive such there are such bubbles
beginners
can’t figure back she’s ready to yawn he
still I can attribute it to age in
general, they also have features so onlookers
rejoice well and far from being the
youngest Levon Aronian is leading in the tournament
he’s better with us  everyone apparently manages to
cope with the excitement in this in this
tournament, so everyone understood to me that it’s important
not just how to create stars from the sky
and not to substitute,
and because  he was lucky with the symbols
before the dubious first round I can
so hopelessly
he did not substitute anything, as it were, average in the
number of moves why the rest
it shows the result quietly
creeping up because they also do not
differ in something but the Chinese they are there I
don’t remember the tables to approximate and
tell me please  my future
plans, what I think is what
to land soon will ask married to the
board, this is already a plus such a simple tradition they
invite after how many there
in three weeks there Japan to move to
960 there, as it were, there is no need to learn theories in words,
so it can only languish
on  what good created meat to create we of
course follow the performance we will be glad to
return to the board even if this is a
little informal until the format before
in the sauce from I said something
I can’t refuse turning because this place
reminds me of
youth because there is a
chess atmosphere in general there is a chess atmosphere  she
returns there those mountains are burning chess was held
in high esteem by  well, well,
thank you very much, but
they are rushing us here, they say that they are starting new sivkov,
thank you, thank you tangerines